The meaning that sustains you
in life and responsibility,
which is not a case that's made very
effectively but needs to be made.
Because most of the meaning that
people experience in their lives that's
worthwhile is a consequence of,
of adopting voluntary responsibility.
How do you mean?
Well,
you think about the people you admire,
her,
the reason that you get
out of bed on a hard day,
it's because you have worthwhile things
to do that you think are necessary and
important.
And those usually involve at
minimum taking care of yourself.
But if you're,
if you're,
if you're developed in
a reasonable manner,
then you have a family to take care
of and you have a community to set,
right?
And you have things that need to be
done to reduce the amount of unnecessary
suffering in the world and to constrain
the amount of malevolence that you
manifest or that you encounter and you
need that sort of meaning to offset the
fact that life is difficult.
The,
the title of your book
is at 12 rules for life,
an antidote to cows and
I come to chaos laser.
But the 12 rules as you read them,
standup state,
just shoulders back,
don't get children,
do anything that makes you dislike
them at set your house in perfect order
before you criticize the world app.
Get kind of,
they sound like common sense,
common sense.
But if people forget why
common sense is common,
you know,
it's common for a reason or and and in,
in then if those common
sense dictums are challenged,
people don't necessarily know how
to defend them because they're,
they seem self evident.
So partly what I've done in the book
is to take things that people know,
um,
and purposefully so,
and to outline why they're true and
conceptually and philosophically,
but also why they're necessary
to apply practically.
And to do both of those at the same time
cause abstract conceptions aren't much
use unless you can nail them
down to something that's
practically implementable.
And so I made sure I bridged
the gap between those,
those,
what extremes in the book.
What,
what do you think makes
you so controversial?
Well,
I think that's a,
that's a good question.
I mean many things are controversial in
today's politically polarized climate.
And everything gets politicized.
I am controversial.
I became embroiled in
controversy in part because of,
uh,
because I'm no friend of
the collectivist left wing.
And I've made that very
clear and I objected to some
legislation in Canada that
was passed that compelled speech
in a manner that had never been,
never been attempted in any system that
utilizes English common law and which I
thought and still believe it was an
absolutely appalling piece of legislation.
But to push it simply for our listeners,
that's me patronizing the listeners.
But I mean,
you talk about these things at length,
it has to do,
no,
you tell me what it has to do with,
well,
it has to do as far as I'm concerned
with the attempts by a coterie of
relatively radical left wing collectivist
to establish linguistic dominance in
certain conceptual spheres.
So for example,
we have the idea that gender expression
and gender identity are purely socially
constructed and also,
um,
independent of biology.
That's basically be written into
the legal fabric in Canada now.
And that's preposterous.
It's factually incorrect,
overwhelmingly factually incorrect.
And it's purely ideological stance.
But people do w trans as they say,
and he put a Stencil,
really are female do
become male and vice versa.
Yeah.
But that doesn't mean that they very
independently things can be linked in
still,
I'm still variation.
Well the overwhelming majority of people
who are biologically male identify as
male.
It's more than 99.9% and the
overwhelming majority of people who are
biologically female identify
as female and are heterosexual.
And so the idea that those
things are independent is insane.
They're not even close to independent.
That doesn't mean there aren't,
there aren't exceptions.
And when you're crafting laws,
especially when it's associated
with scientific facts,
you have to get your terminology right.
The claim of the social constructionists
is that all of these areas,
uh,
biological sex,
gender expression,
gender identity,
um,
so sexual preference vary independently
and it's all a consequence of
socialization.
That's wrong.
It's wrong at every
single level of analysis.
And it's important.
Well,
there are biological influences play
a major role on people obviously.
And not only that,
as your societies become more egalitarian,
and this has been demonstrated
clearly in the Scandinavian countries,
as societies become more egalitarian
in their social policies,
the differences between
men and women get bigger,
not smaller.
How well,
because it turns out that if you flatten
out the socio cultural structure,
which is one of the things that make men
and women the same as it turns out the
biological differences maximize.
So the biggest differences
in personality and interest,
which partly determines
occupational choice.
For example,
the biggest differences are in the
Scandinavian countries and they've grown.
Has the Scandinavian countries,
Scandinavian countries have
become more egalitarian.
And how does that manifest?
What manifests itself and
occupational choice for example,
but and but also in in personality.
How do you mean in occupation or choice?
I mean there are fewer women in the
stem studies as societies in the stem
fields,
science,
technology,
engineering and mathematics.
As societies become more egalitarian,
fewer women go into the stem fields,
not more.
And it looks like it's a
consequence of their free choice.
Partly because the personality
differences between men and women,
between men and women grow as
societies become more equal.
And so do the differences
in their interest.
It's because men and women are actually
biologically different to some degree.
Now,
you know,
men and women are quite the,
quite similar.
So for example,
if you look at a trait like aggression,
if you pick a random man and a random
woman out of the population and you had to
lay a bet on who was more aggressive,
if you bet on the woman,
you'd be right 40% of the time,
which an yes.
And so that's quite an overlap,
right?
But then if you go out to the extremes
and if you had to pick the one in 100
most aggressive person,
it would almost always be male.
And that's why so many men are in prison.
So it's 10 to one males
to female in prison.
Now.
And that's partly because you can have
very much similarity in population
overlap in the middle,
but quite a lot of
difference at the extremes.
You.
It was alleged that you made
very controversial remarks
following the m Harvard
events in Toronto where a man who's at,
I presume we'll do life killed,
I think it was 10 people and
drove insurable and wanted
to do more and arising
from that,
it was implied that somehow that this
had to do with the fact that he couldn't
have sex with a woman.
Well,
you said it was alleged that
I make controversial comments.
That's exactly right.
You got the terminology right there.
What I pointed out was that social in
enforcement of monogamous norms is one way
that societies around the world,
male aggression at bay,
and that's an absolutely solid finding
from a hundred years of anthropology,
one that's often cited
by people on the left.
So what happened in the New York Times
article that you're referring to was that
that was taken radically out of context
and their old reporter knew that
perfectly well.
She was very intelligent young woman.
She knew exactly what she
was doing when she did that,
and to make the case that
monogamous social norms,
which are pretty much
universal around the world,
by the way,
even though people have some
tendency towards multiple partners,
the reason that monogamous social norms
emerge is partly to keep male aggression
under control.
That's not controversial.
Anybody who knows the anthropological
psychological literature understands it's,
that's the purpose of it.
Well,
there's a variety of purposes,
but that's definitely one.
Polygamous societies are way more violent,
not a little bit more violent,
way more violent.
Yeah,
so that's part of the purpose.
There's a variety of purposes.
You want people to have longterm stable
partners because that's probably better
for men and women in general.
Now the,
well,
yes,
that would be good if,
if it,
if it can be managed in how,
I think on many situations
that's a luxury.
I mean,
people have hard lives,
have had hard lives throughout history,
and they've made decisions for,
for very basic economic reasons.
If,
if your relationship is
also characterized by love,
great.
But you know,
life is very difficult for people and
has been for a very long period of time.
The primary reason that
monogamy is enforced socially
is for children as far as
I can tell,
because of course obviously children are
dependent for very long periods of time
and we know even in western societies,
which are relatively prosperous,
people who serve as single parents tend
to plummet down the economic hierarchy
because it's very,
very difficult to have a
fulltime productive job and
take care of children by
yourself.
And we also know the literature on
child development indicates w beyond the
shadow of the doubt,
the two parent families are far more
effective with regards to the outcome of
children than single parent families,
which is an imagine many people
we'd be ringing in to say not to,
not to handle,
they want.
There's a literature developed on this
that's developed over decades that
indicates this extraordinarily clearly.
So fatherlessness for example,
is a very potent predictor of
negative outcomes among children.
That doesn't mean that every person
who's a single parent is doing a bad job.
Those are not the same claims.